مسلسل النهارده مكسر الدنيا السنه دي مكسر
الدنيا لما طلع من السجن في ريحته وما
فرحتش لان هو ما ردش حقه في ساعتها احنا
كنا هنوزع شربات في الشارع
وزغاريد بقى
والدنيا حلوه الصراحه لا هو راجل محترم
يعني الف مبروك يا استاذ جعفر بس انا عارف
ان هو كده كده اخرك ذكي هو كان بص في
ساعته وبسع كمان فانا عارف المسلسل معروف
اصلا حلو كويس ان هو طلع وراءه كان كده
لازم يطلع وراه اصلا بطل المسلسل وبتاع لو
ما اخذش حقه انا هنزل اجيب حقه كله اللي
جعفر ههه المعلم جعفر طلع بالسلامه وان
شاء الله يرجع ياخد حقه من عيله فتح الله
واحنا فوق ورا ورا جعفر العمده لحد لما
يعرف ان سيف ابنه يجيب حقه باذن الله لم
تابعه رامز والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيه
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب
للاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات